ok let's get into audience questions for
the first time in 2019 2019 we're
already seeing a lot of changes from
2018 politically Democrats have been
sworn in and taking control of the House
Nancy Pelosi is the Speaker of the House
we already are seeing investigations
ramped up we are seeing bills get passed
to reopen the government despite the
fact that Republicans and Trump are not
when even consider doing that on the
basis of a democratically passed bill so
a lot of the questions today sort of
relate to the next steps in the current
regime the first question is hey David
will anybody in the Trump family flip
and start cooperating with Robert molars
investigation I think the answer is
basically no with the exception that so
I'm trying to know offhand the full
family tree of the Trump child spouses
and that sort of thing I know that Don
junior now is dating that current or
former fox news anchor kimberly
guilfoyle so he has his there's his
ex-wife who's floating around out there
as of what I would imagine a possible
more likely person to flip and start
cooperating with Muller that's a
possibility if there were if there was
pressure applied to her to try to figure
out what Don junior was up to although
the law around sort of spousal
incrimination may make it so that she
doesn't really feel the pressure that's
a possibility I don't really see it as
particularly likely because there is
this you know with Trump there's this
unending loyalty until you say anything
even mildly critical of him and then all
of a sudden you're like the worst person
Michael Cohen's a good example of this
man afford has been thrown under the bud
you know that the entire the entire
thing we sort of know how it works and
it does seem like within family at least
so far we haven't seen that breakdown
where where Trump flips on a family
member but what what I think is
new in 2019 is that we've not seen
Donald Trump operate as president yet
when he doesn't control every element of
government he has now lost the house and
a trump president without control of the
house with the at this point who even
knows what the full number of
investigations is going to be that we
see Democrats in the House undertake to
try to figure out what exactly went down
with Donald Trump that could change
things and just because we've not seen
the flipping on family before we we
could we could see that one other thing
Trump is clearly capable of throwing his
family under the bus we found out that
in the aftermath of the breaking news of
the Trump Tower meeting which Donald
Trump jr. was a big player in Trump got
involved himself in drafting that bogus
statement that was published which was
riddled with lies we now know
retrospectively about the Trump Tower
meeting and there are numerous reports
that he was just absolutely furious with
Don jr. and that actually correlates
with just bigger picture history of the
Trump family stuff that Trump and Don
jr. have not always gotten along so I
think that if you are going to see an
immediate family member not like an ex
family member or someone by marriage if
you're gonna see an immediate family
member
flip and we start to see a divergence in
the public paths of whether they're on
the same page or not it would be Trump
senior Donald Trump and Don junior I
think that's the most likely beyond that
I mean you know I want to sort of
mention Jared Kushner because he is the
golden boy for Donald Trump but it's not
you know what you would call a blood
relative and if there were to be someone
else if it really got ugly where you
would see them take sort of opposing
positions in this entire thing maybe it
would be Jared Kushner send me your
thoughts am i way off here is there
somebody I mean people might say Tiffany
she clearly hates Trump already she may
just be out of the public's
light and I don't know that she would
even really know anything such that she
would be a target to flip so I would say
Don jr. done Jr's ex-wife Don jr. Jared
Kushner sort of in that order